prescrivait du sport sur ordonnance
est-ce que vous accepteriez non non
parce que les sponsors domaine de
nous-mêmes ce d'être spontané du sport
s'est bougé sait déjà c'est la demande
croissante est déjà assurée médecin m'a
prescrit japon c'est bon pour moi
bien qu'on a pas besoin de moi
personnellement je fais du sport donne à
son ordonnance ce serait bien parce que
on a du poids à perdre après les fêtes
du sport sur ordonnance cela peut faire
sourire
c'est pourtant l'une des préconisations
d'un nouveau rapport parlementaire pour
aider la population à se prendre en main
ce rapport part d'un constat le coût de
certaines activités sportives le sous
équipement en infrastructures et la
réticence à montrer encore obèses sont
autant de freins qui ne favorise pas la
pratique d'un sport
pour y remédier il faudrait donc
développer les équipements sportifs
inciter les médecins à prescrire le
sport sur ordonnance et créer une
licence sportive sociale pour les
populations les plus démunies
il faut que nos collègues médecins se
saisissent de leurs j'avais dire de ce
que leur métier leur offre c'est à dire
la possibilité de faire de l'éducation
avec les parents se faire l'éducation
avec les enfants de discuter sur
l'alimentation et de discuter sur
l'activité physique nécessaire frédéric
depiesse est un des médecins qui était
auditionné par les parlementaires
un professionnel qui milite pour inciter
monsieur madame tout le monde a une
pratique régulière du sport et pour
cause selon une étude de 2016 la
martinique compte 27,8 % des plus de 16
ans obèses contre 14 5 % dans l'hexagone
le rapport des députés était aussi
important de rappeler qu'il faut
communiquer il faut que l'information a
jusqu à monsieur
un tout le monde à la maison pour que
les gens se disent oui finalement si moi
aussi j'ai un peu de surpoids moi aussi
je suis éventuellement obèses je dois me
prendre en main et je dois bouger
le rapport préconise quelques quarante
trois propositions une préoccupation
prise en compte également par la ctm et
la rs le 12 décembre dernier une
convention a été signée pour mettre en
commun un programme d'actions concrètes
par exemple en incitant à consommer
local des produits sains et diversifiée